in biology it's useful to have some
shared language so we can communicate
and describe the world around us in ways
that we can all understand together
so here we're going to talk about
populations communities and ecosystems
and as we'll see these are all related
ideas
so first of all a population is talking
about the members of a specific species
in an area
so for example in this picture we have a
population of zebra
i have one zebra there one zebra there
there might be some others that we can't
see in fact there are likely to be so
these are each members of a population
of zebra now we have other populations
in this picture we have a population of
buffalo these three are members of that
population we have a population of
antelope in fact there is a bunch of
antelope in this picture so we have many
members of that population we even see
some animals here in the background i
can't quite make out what they are but
that could be a different population
let's say if those are elephants they
might be elephants the way i see them
but that could be members of a
population of elephants so if that is a
population
what is a community
well a community is all of the living
species that live in the same area so we
have a community of animals that is made
up of populations of buffalo of zebra
and of antelope and i want to make clear
that the populations or when we're
talking about the communities we're not
necessarily just talking about large
animals like this we could be talking
about populations of mosquitoes we could
be talking about populations of fish in
this pond if there are any fish we could
have a population of a certain species
of plant likewise when we're talking
about communities we're talking about
collectively all of the living organisms
together now last but not least what
would be an ecosystem then
well an ecosystem is all of the living
organisms plus all of the non-living
things so the ecosystem that we see here
would also include the water it would
also include the dirt it would also
include the air and organisms like those
that we see right here are constantly
interacting with both the living and
non-living parts of their environment
these interactions are how organisms get
food shelter water and warmth these
interactions are how organisms survive
and produce offspring so let's get a
little bit more practice with this idea
of populations communities and
ecosystems and we will do that by
looking at this picture right over here
pause this video and think about what
are the populations here
well you might not know the name of all
these different types of fish but you
can see that there's a population of
this gold colored fish right over here
there's also another population of this
blue colored fish
we could keep looking for other
populations looks like there's a
population of this silver colored or i
guess longish silver fish right over
here but once again it's not just the
fish there's a population of coral
there's populations of microorganisms
that we can't see here
the community would be all of these
living organisms that live close to each
other and we'll see sometimes they
compete with each other sometimes they
eat each other but sometimes they help
each other or sometimes they don't
matter that much to each other and we'll
study that into a lot in a lot more
detail and then the ecosystem includes
all of the above plus the water plus the
oxygen that is in the water plus the
sand at the bottom of the ocean
so i'll leave you there hopefully you
now have a sense of what biologists are
talking about when they talk about
populations communities and ecosystems